et
[Musique]
on n'en est pas là daraîche je suis
auteur compositeur est après je fais ma
carrière dans la musique entre je viens
d'une famille de musiciens gaspésie tout
le monde chez - mes parents chanter mes
frères mes soeurs chaque maison enfin
champs étant donné qu'on est gaspésien
c'est notre valeur la plus sûre c'est la
famille c'est d'ailleurs ça peut passer
la philosophie du 4e d'abord on passe un
maniaque parce qu'ils chantaient [ __ ]
ma mère aussi
j'ai beaucoup de chansons que j'ai
enregistrée au début de ma carrière mes
premiers albums
ces bons chanteurs
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé ma carrière elle
chantait des grandes jada grandes
chansons françaises soient les espaces
étaient bande aurait percé un bar
gaspésien salut national andré simard
jean thériault pour le fun et cool après
l'histoire est arrivée bien directement
faire d'album le monde des mobiles
non je crois que j'ai entendu c'est ce
que finalement fait un album pour le
font depuis 25 ans en fait 4 go ou des
premiers ça ce n'est tellement mangé il
s'est tellement curie était juste avions
ravitailleurs techs naïf vous que je
trouvais au deuxième album il s'apprend
c'est un jugement loin le producteur
joue il m'a dit de faire la trame sonore
au moi j'aimerais faire mouche en 2005
il a dit oui salliot ben j'ai aimé
seulement vidéo puis jets de briques
jaunes colis et puis il s'est accru pour
arranger ce que je me pose c'est ce que
j'ai fait que avec les moyens la bible
et commencer à faire de mon dieu d'aider
des piats d'ondés dévoile des cartes et
des accords mineurs dans le bolton qui
savait si c'est pour jouer le côté
finalement c'est la fin de ma soeur
julie si j'ai fait cette carrière lieu
de cette façon j'aurais pu faire une
carrière plus sérieuse plus traqué
[Musique]